as I said Rudy you were America's mayor
during 9 11. everyone loved you like
your approval ratings were the highest
in the country how do you feel uh having
this Legacy that has been tarnished you
know and he's like I don't give a
about my legacy I'm standing up for what
I believe in and there's something to be
said with that whether you agree with
someone like Rudy Giovanni or not
um and you know the whole election
denial thing I don't think is a winning
message Like Pat mentioned
um they can't see for even mentioning it
yeah but but I don't I don't
I forget about the canceling part I
don't care about the canceling part what
I care about is is that a message of a
winner
it's not the message of a winner is what
like okay Jimmy Butler lost
okay game six I'm at the game Courtside
I'm watching this thing the place is
like he is the third free throw this is
game over with there's 2.4 seconds left
they add 0.6 seconds that's not a big
deal it's totally fine don't call it
time I'll do anything with it that point
six seconds they added is the reason why
they lost Duncan Robinson misses two
three-pointers wide open he hits one of
them it's game over right Jimmy Butler
in the interview here's what he says
well first of all we would have won if I
would have played a better game
we would have won if I would have played
a better game there's something so
attractive about a guy with that kind of
a mindset that is a very very attractive
mindset Michael had it Kobe had it I'm a
die-hard Laker fan I'm not rooting for
the Lakers simply because the guy that's
there right now it's just he posted a
story today on Instagram talking about
you guys will remember it but I don't
even know why you don't have me at my
number one wait till I leave the game
then you'll realize who says stuff like
that it's just that's not that's that's
somebody that needs attention how much
more attention do you need you're you're
LeBron James you don't need to be
about something like that just not
attractive it's a weak quality of a
leader so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]